كشفت صحيفتها ارتس عن تعمد جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي حرق مئات من المنازل داخل قطع
غزه بكل ما فيها من ممتلكات وذلك على نحو
يجعلها غير صالحه للسكن او الاستخدام
ونقلت الصحيفه عن ثلاثه ضباط يقودون
العمليات العسكريه في غزه قولهم ان عمليات
حرق المنازل في القطاع تمت باوامر ضباط
ميدانيين دون مسوغ قانوني ودون الحصول على
الموافقه القض ئيه
اللازمه الاطلاع على الاوضاع في غلاف غزه
تنضم الينا نجوان سمري نجوان كيف هي
التطورات
وكيف تتعامل اسرائيل مع سقوط مزيد من
ضباطها وجنودها في معارك
غزه نعم بالفعل جلال بحسب بيان الناطق
العسكري الاسرائيلي صباح هذا ال اليوم فان
قواته تواصل العمل العسكري في مناطق
مختلفه قال بان التركيز يتواصل تحديدا في
منطقه خان يونس لا سما في غربها وفي مخيم
خان يونس وقال في بيانه الصباحي ان قواته
عثرت على منصه لاطلاق صواريخ بعيده المدى
وقام الطيران الحربي الاسرائيلي بتدميرها
ومن جهه اخرى اكد بان القوات ما زالت تعمل
ايضا في مناطق الشمال وفي مناطق الوسط
واشار بانه في خلال الساعات ال4 الماضيه
قامت القوات بقتل عشرات المسلحين
الفلسطينيين بالاضافه الى ذلك قال بان بان
ال العمل في تحديدا في المناطق الشماليه
يتركز في منطقه جباليا والاحياء الشرقيه
لهذه المناطق بخصوص الاعلان يوم امس عن
مقتل ضابط اخر في المعارك تحديدا في منطقه
شمال غزه وهو من وحده شلدا وحده النخبه في
سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي وهو يضاف الى ضابط
اخر وجنديين قتلا في المعارك يوم امس نقرا
هذا اليوم على سبيل المثال في صحيفه دعوت
احرونوت مقالا
يتحدث فيه عن قضيه اشراك وحدات النخبه في
هذه ال الحرب ويقول بان هذه الخسائر التي
يسجلها الجيش الاسرائيلي في هذه المعارك
من خلال
مقتل جنود وضباط من قوات الوحده تعد خسائر
فادحه للجيش الاسرائيلي لا سما وانه بدايه
هذه الحرب قرر ال الجيش باشراك هذه
الوحدات التي عاده لا تشارك بالعمليات
البريه ولكن تم اشراكها من منطلق انها
ستقوم بقياده هذه العمليات على نحو اكبر
لكنه يشير على نحو افضل ولكنه يشير المحلل
العسكري يوسي ه شوع الى ان هذا يكبد الجيش
الاسرائيلي خسائر فادحه لان تاهيل هؤلاء
الضباط في وحدات النخ النخبه يتطلب وقت
طويل من جهه وايضا ميزانيات ماليه اكبر من
تاهيل بطبيعه الحال ال جنود في وحدات اخرى
ويتطرق بذلك الى عدد اي للمره الاولى على
سبيل المثال يقول تسجل وحده شداك في سلاح
الجو الاسرائيلي هذا العدد من الضباط
القتلى تسعه من ضباط هذه الوحده قتلوا منذ
بدايه هذه الحرب وهو يؤكد بان ذلك يعد
خساره فادحه للجيش الاسرائيلي وبالتالي
هكذا ربما من جهه يحاول المسؤولون السياس
السياسيون والعسكريون القول بان الضباط
يتقدمون القتال ويشاركون القتال لكن من
الواضح ان لذلك تاثير كبير على الجيش وعلى
الشارع الاسرائيلي ايضا عندما يتم تسجيل
هذا العدد من القتلى بشكل كبير ما بين
الجنود ولكن تحديدا من قوات النخبه ووحدات
النخ النخبه التابعه للجيش الاسرائيلي من
جهه اخرى هذا الكشف لصحيفه هارت هو واستند
بالاساس على فيديوهات نشرها جنود في
الاسابيع الاخيره الماضيه من داخل غزه وهم
يقومون بالاحتفاء بعمليات اضرام نيران
واسعه في منازل ال الفلسطينيين
وبحسب من كتب هذا المقال فانه توجه
بالسؤال للجيش الاسرائيلي رسميا الجيش قال
بانه سيقوم بفحص هذه القضيه لكنه يقول بان
ثلاثه من الضباط
الذين يقودون القتال في قطاع غزه اكدوا له
انه يتم حرق المنازل وقد تم بالفعل حرق
مئات المنازل حتى الان خلال الشهر الاخير
جلال شكرا لك نجوان في غلاف
غزه